play music jazz our cars give us where
we're going
while our phones keep us connected the
Android auto development course from
Udacity built in collaboration with
Google will show you how making your
Android app available in the car is as
easy as extending your existing code the
course focuses on plain audio and
handling messages so that your users can
stay connected with their hands on the
wheel and eyes on the road take a road
trip with us to learn how to expose
contact control playback and customize
the UI for playing audio as well as how
to show notifications playback messages
and reply by voice follow this link to
get started now